so as those of you guys who follow me on
Twitter are aware I've been spending the
last few days trying to find a way to
make a video about Dr Doom that makes
sense to do his character Justice
because Dr Doom has been in everything
and so because he's such a difficult
character to do what we're going to do
is we're going I'm going to basically
give you guys a chronology to a degree
of some of the stories he was in I'm
really going to highlight the finer
points but we're also going to get into
the discussion about Dr Doom proper
we're going to look beyond the pages and
we're going to get into him as a person
to see why it is that Dr Doom gets
involved in the kind of campaigns that
he
does so Dr Doom first appeared in
Fantastic 4 issue number five in
1962 and in the novel Silver age art of
comic books what we found was that an
interview had previously been done with
Jack Kirby around 1987 or so and this
interview was cited in this novel
whereby Jack Kirby had stated that Dr
Doom was designed the way he was because
he was supposed to be indicative of
death he was supposed to look like death
the actual character death in the sense
that he would have a hood over his head
he would have this armor that would take
away the humanity and make him look
almost inhuman as if he wasn't of the
planet Earth he was part of some sort of
maybe superstitious or mystical realm in
addition when they were looking for a
name for Dr Doom they had simply just
settled on Dr Doom they wanted to create
a villain that would be on par and equal
to the popularity of the Fantastic Four
and the name Dr Doom was as menacing as
it was simple and elegant and so what we
found with his initial debut is that he
simply just arrives at the backer
building one day that he simply goes out
to The Fantastic 4 and what he says is
the Fantastic 4 have to hand over Susan
storm if they don't hand over Susan
storm then he's going to attack the rest
of New York and destroy the backer
building and so the Fantastic for really
seeing no other option here given that
Dr Doom has basically disabled their
defenses hand over Susan storm and the
goal here is to find out what it is that
Dr Doom wants now what Reed Richards
does is give us this sort of backstory
about Dr Doom but we'll get get into
that here in a minute but what happens
is that Dr Doom basically takes Susan
storm uses her as a hostage and with her
as a hostage then instructs the
remainder of the Fantastic Four Reed
Richards Ben grim and Johnny Storm that
they have to travel into the past in
order to capture the jewels of
Blackbeard the pirate and what this will
do unbeknown to the Fantastic 4 is it
will grant Dr Doom the power he needs to
make himself virtually omnipotent and
the rule of planet Earth and so what
happens is Reed Richards Johnny Storm
and Ben Grim jump into the past and when
they jump into the past they of course
disguise themselves as pirates they
board Blackbeard ship and they
successfully managed to acquire the
jewels but the problem here is that Reed
Richard begins to realize that if Dr
Doom is pursuing these Jewels then
chances are there's something about
these jewels that will be used for
nefarious purposes and so what he does
is he replaces the jewels with worthless
chains and then takes the chest back to
the present when he's brought back by Dr
Doom and so what happens is when Dr Doom
confronts the Fantastic Four he realized
izes that the jewels have been replaced
with worthless chains and so as a result
the Fantastic Four together succeed in
defeating this version of Dr Doom but
what they learn is this isn't actually
Dr Doom himself instead this is a
doombot and this is the first time that
we ever actually see doombots in Marvel
Comics when Dr Doom himself first
appears now the way the doombots are
designed by Dr Doom we actually learned
this later on in Marvel Comics is the
doombots are designed for each one to
think it's Dr Doom but to follow the
orders of the real Dr Doom so that if
for any reason whatsoever Dr Doom were
to send a doombot out in his stad to the
world as a whole it would be Dr Doom
itself it would seem as though he would
speak in the same manner of Dr Doom he
would have the same memories of Dr Doom
and so to the world that is Dr Doom now
of course with this uh doombot being
destroyed Dr Doom himself Reveals His uh
reveals that that this was a doombot
that he still uh I guess is away from
the Fantastic Four he traps the
remainder of the Fantastic Four he traps
Reed Richards Ben grim and Johnny storm
inside of a room while Susan storm is
still held captive next to Dr Doom and
then begins to draw the oxygen away so
that Reed Richards Ben grim and Johnny
Storm will start to suffocate and so
during this time what Susan storm does
is she uses her ability to make herself
invisible and begins to sneak away now
she's successfully able to access a
hidden hatch or a hidden uh I guess
opening switch for the door which allows
the remainder of the Fantastic Four to
to uh to live but that in the end he's
basically going to try to capture them
try to defeat them and this will be an
ongoing theme with his character now two
years after his initial introduction in
1964 with Fantastic 4 Annual issue
number two we get the origin story of Dr
Doom now the way the origin story is
given to us is actually quite simple
here in a way where it really just wraps
things up in a very easy to understand
concept what we learned here with this
origin story was that at some point in
the past in Latveria Dr Doom was the
child of a woman named Cynthia Von Doom
and a man and the problem here was that
his mother had died at some previous
point in time in this initial origin
story we're not really told how that
happens we're simply just told that
she's gone but we're also informed that
she in some manner had been dabbling in
the dark arts and so the possibility
existed that Victor Von Doom could
inherit her ability to tap into
mysticism what we also know is that uh
among this Gypsy tribe that Victor Von
Doom lives that his father is basically
the leader of this tribe and that his
father is more or less their medicine
man he's basically their spiritual
healer and even their physical healer
and so what we find is that the baron of
Laria at the time contacts or sends
soldiers out for the father of Victor
Von Doom and the hopes that Victor Von
Doom's father will be able to cure The
Baron's wife of some ailment that she
has now initially we're just told that
she's sick in this origin story it's
actually not until much later on when we
get into the Books of Doom by Ed
Brubaker that we learn she actually has
cancer but the fact remains that Victor
Von Doom's father is not able to cure
this woman and so as a result what he
does is uh Victor Von Doom and his
father escaped Latveria before the uh
before the baron can find out that his
wife is going to die and when she
actually dies he sends soldiers after
Victor Von Doom and uh and his father
now over the course of their attempt to
escape they end up in what I would
assume to be the uh maybe the Swiss Alps
or maybe Siberia or something like that
but the fact remains that Victor Von
Doom's father freezes to death and so as
a result Victor Von Doom Retreats back
to Latveria back to the Gypsy Camp
whereby enough time has passed that
they're no longer being pursued and then
uh basically forces himself into the
role of being the leader of this Gypsy
camp now what he also does is he
discovers the chest of his mother and
after discovering the chess of his
mother he begins to dabble in science
and mysticism now we're not really told
why it is that Victor Von Doom is as
smart as he is all we're told is that
Victor Von Doom is just extremely smart
for his age and so as a result he uses
his vast intelligence alongside his
ability to learn extremely fast and he
basically begins to adapt and to meld
science and mysticism into one which
allows him to advance technology among
his tribe in a way that was hither to
unseen and even supersedes the uh the
powers or the capabilities of the baron
and his forces and so as a result he
basically begins to wage this sort of
one-man war against uh against the baron
by uh using Guerilla Warfare tactics
throwing grenades different things like
that but
ultimately what we find is that his
actions Garner the attention of the
United States government and so what
happens is a general is sent to Latveria
to meet with Victor Von Doom and offers
Victor Von Doom the opportunity to
travel to the United States to study at
Empire State University and to basically
further the attempts of uh of the US
government and to expand on his own
knowledge of Science and uh and so on
and so what we find is that when Victor
Von Doom travels to Empire State
University he meets Reed Richards but he
also meets Ben Grim now almost
immediately after Reed Richards and
Victor Von do meet they become enemies
not necessarily because Reed Richards
has it out for Victor Von Doom but
because at this point Victor Von Doom is
is uh very caught up he's very arrogant
about his intelligence and so for him
it's really a waste of time for him to
spend any time with anybody in that area
because they simply can't keep up with
him and so what we find is that Victor
Von Doom is attempting to basically
access the nether realm what would be
referred to as hell now again in this
original or origin story we're not given
the basis for that but what we'll do is
we'll actually fill in the gaps as we
progress throughout the story of Victor
Von Doom but what happens here is Victor
Von Doom building a machine of sorts
tries access another realm and then the
machine simply explodes and so as a
result Victor Von Doom's face is scarred
and so following this Victor Von Doom
travels to uh to Tibet to basically
learn more about science and Magic from
Mystics he enhances his abilities and
then he travels back to Latveria which
pretty much ends this original origin
story and fantastic for Annual issue
number two basically uh Stanley and Jack
Kirby telling us this is how we end up
with this version of Victor Von Doom now
in terms of filling in the gap apps here
what we found was that in 1971 with
astonishing Tales issue number eight
written by Roy Thomas and Gary Friedrich
they had simply told us that in some
form or another that uh Cynthiana Von
Doom the mother of Victor Von Doom had
been dabbling in mysticism and formed a
pack with Mesto and the goal here was
for her to gain enough power to
basically overthrow the baron of
Latveria and to basically give her home
or give a home to the to the gypsies as
a true home for themselves now initially
she didn't really want to make a pack
with misto but Mesto had basically uh
prayed on her desire to provide a home
for her son her husband and herself and
so once she gave in to the paack of
Mesto we found that she had developed or
I guess she had been given these
abilities but couldn't control them and
so when she had attacked be the baron of
Latveria along with his forces while she
was successful in killing a multitude of
soldiers she was mortally injured in the
process and so as a result once she
traveled back to uh back to her home she
died but she warned her husband to keep
Victor Von D away from the mystics and
the things that she had used in order to
achieve the power that she had now in
addition to this we jumped to Ed Brew
Baker's Books of Doom in 2006 and what
Ed Brewbaker did is he used all these
different concepts Jack Kirby and stanle
story of Victor Von Doom John Burns run
of Victor Von Doom which we'll get into
and what he did is he combined all these
things into one six-part origin story
that basically made things a whole lot
easier here and what he basically says
is that from the time that Victor Von
Doom realized that his mother was dead
the time that he was old enough to
basically begin using her powers or
using her uh her knowledge and her
studies everything he did existed for
the purpose of finding a way to travel
to hell to get his mother's Soul freed
from the clutches of Mesto what he tells
us is that when he uh when he had
traveled to Empire State University when
he had developed this machine that while
the world had seemed as though the
machine had simply just exploded for
Victor Von Doom what had happened here
is he had penetrated the nether realm he
had spoken with Mesto and Mesto had
taunted Victor Von Doom in saying that
Victor Von Doom's mother will remain in
the clutches of uh of Mesto for eternity
but what he also said is that he'll make
a deal with Victor Von Doom and the deal
is Victor Von Doom will be able to fight
for his mother's Freedom once a year and
that every time Victor Von Doom fails
his people in laveria will hate him more
and more but Victor Vue makes this
sacrifice in the hopes that he can free
his mother's Soul now again this origin
story from 2006 really kind of wraps in
the astonishing Tales issue number eight
by Roy Thomas and Gary Friedrich in that
an astonishing Tales what we found was
that while do strange and Dr Doom were
fighting or I guess they were uh working
with one another to free the soul of Dr
Doom's mother that in the end they're
successful and her soul is freed and
allowed to go to heaven but nonetheless
this was the basis behind everything Dr
Doom did in the early days this is the
basis behind everything that he was
trying to achieve now what we found was
that by 1981 one that John burn had
taken over the role of writing for the
Fantastic Four and John burn is
considered by all standards of
measurement in relation the comic book
fans the quintessential Fantastic 4
writer in terms of what it was he did
for the Fantastic 4 as a whole as well
as humanizing Dr Doom now a lot of the
emphasis for John burn is given on Dr
Doom we of course have characters or I
guess writers like Mark Wade we have
Jonathan Hickman who had fantastic runs
with the Fantastic Four but the fact
remains is that John burn is usually at
the top of the list whenever people talk
about Fantastic Four writers now among
the things that John burn had done he of
course had basically taken Susan storm
and made her a woman as opposed to being
referred to as the invisible girl he had
given her confidence he had built her
into one of the strongest members of the
team and so this is why we saw that in
the 1980s she had transitioned from the
invisible girl to the invisible woman
but again the most notable action here
of John burn was humanizing Dr Doom
because again up to this point Dr Doom
was simply just a villain who basically
attacked people he had his own campaigns
but no one really knew why it was that
he was doing these things he would just
show up he would make life a hassle for
people for a little while and then he
would go away and so what we found was
that coming after John Burn's run of the
Fantastic for in uh issue number 293
when John burn left that this
humanization of Dr Doom would carry on
in subsequent stories now one of the
other more important things when it came
to the character of Dr Doom was the
secret Wars The Secret Wars again much
like John Burn's run of the Fantastic 4
placed Dr Doom in a whole new light now
the secret wars were written by Jim
shooter and this was basically one of
the first massive crossover events in
Marvel Comics which is one of the
reasons why it's considered the most
popular story or the most popular
Crossover in Marvel Comics and it's also
probably the reason why Marvel is basing
their reboot of their continuity off of
Secret Wars but the fact remains here
that during the secret War conflict of
course as we know the beyonder had uh
captured a bunch of superheroes and
super villains he' put them on the
planet on Battle world and made them
fight one another but almost immediately
after secret war starts and the very
first issue Dr Doom's main goal is to
capture the power of the beyonder now
again given what we've talked about so
far the basis behind Dr Doom capturing
the power of the beyonder is to find a
way to free his mother's Soul because
this again comes before the doctor
strange and the uh Dr Doom team up in
1989 and so what happens here is that Dr
Doom usually I guess he uses the power
of Galactus to steal the power of the
beyonder and very interesting the way he
does this what happens here is that as
time progresses Galactus begins to
hunger he has to satiate his appetite
for energy and so he uses his Planet
consuming device to try to consume
battle world but as he's about to
consume all of this energy Dr Doom
snatches the energy away from galatis
and puts it within himself giving him
almost unrivaled abilities in terms of
everybody else on Battle world he then
uses the power of Galactus to try to
approach the beyonder and the beyonder
sends him away but the bey's currious
ious as to why it was Dr Doom would
attack him in the first place and so
when the beyonder approaches Dr Doom in
a fleeting moment Dr Doom snatches the
power of the beyonder away now he
doesn't really use them for nefarious
purposes he doesn't really abuse them
here he just uses them for the purpose
of again trying to bring his mother's
Soul Back which is something that he
seems to attempt to do once Secret Wars
is over at the very least that seems to
be what his motive would be but one of
the other big things to come out of
Secret Wars was that we saw the face of
Dr Doom this is something we had never
seen the only time we had seen the face
of Dr Doom was before he had received
his injury during the uh explosion when
he tried to penetrate the ne realm after
that we never saw what his face looked
like now when his face was given to us
in secret Wars his face was completely
pristine it was completely healed and
this is really one of those big things
that belongs to the realm of
interpretation the reason why I say that
is because if you look at Jack Kirby's
run and Stan Le Ron of the Fantastic 4
they argue that the disfigurement is
more of a metaphor it's more more of a
uh depiction of Dr Doom's self-hatred
his face isn't actually scarred but when
you look at John Burn's run of the
Fantastic 4 John Burns says that Dr
Doom's face is physically scarred that
it really is scarred that way either way
the difference here I guess the fact
remains that when Dr Doom makes his face
known to the I guess of the superhero
community on Battle world this is the
first time that we see it now again
following what it was that Jim Shooter
had established with Dr Doom the
humanization of his character following
John Burn's expansion on this with Dr
Doom and the Fantastic Four we saw that
going forward throughout the Marvel
continuity Dr Doom plays a multitude of
roles and he's in almost everything he's
one of the foremost characters that
leads to the road of the Scarlet Witch
developing Insanity as well as gaining
her powers that causes her to lose her
mind and then warp reality during the
House of M storyline Dr Doom of course
is one of the superheroes or I guess one
of the super villains that fights
alongside the Avengers and the X-Men and
so on and seems to sacrifice is life in
the process during the onslaught Saga
and as part of the hero's reborn
universe and getting into the current
day right now that is to say what it is
is taking place at the moment in Marvel
Comics it's been revealed to us by
Jonathan Hickman that Dr Doom is rabom
Al now for me I actually didn't really
see this coming a lot of people say they
have a lot of people say that they've
seen this coming because if you look at
the continuity of Dr Doom Dr Doom is
always pulling the strings whenever
there's a major conflict going on
somewhere Dr Doom is usually the one
that's behind it or at the very least is
involved in it in some capacity but what
we know here is that somewhere along the
line Dr Doom was experimenting and
trying to understand what was going on
with the incursions and so what he had
done is he had met with Owen Reese with
the molecule man and the molecule man
had taken him to the Beyond verse and
what he did was basically tell drct
strange that if I'm sorry Dr Doom that
if Dr Doom is going to understand what
the basis behind the start of the
incursions is he has to travel all the
way back to its point of origin and so
what Jonathan Hickman has basically
given us here is a paradox Jonathan
Hickman has established that when the
incursions initially started that Dr
Doom had seen an incursion take place he
had captured A Shard of the uh of the
planet Earth that was destroyed by the
uh New Avengers during the initial
incursion across Latveria what he then
did was he began to analyze this uh I
guess this piece of rock and then in
turn he use this piece of rock to find
the source in order to travel to it and
thereby cause the incursions to happen
that seems to be what it is that
Jonathan Hickman is doing here with Dr
Doom but again at this moment we're
still waiting on a couple more titles
from New Avengers before we can actually
confirm this but the fact remains that
at this moment right now we don't really
know what's going to happen with Dr Doom
going forward into Secret Wars we don't
know if Dr Doom will be destroyed we
don't know if Dr Doom will destroy the
beyonders we don't know if Dr Doom will
simply continue on and rule over
everybody and battle world this is
simply just an unknown thing here but
the fact remains that given the entire
continuity of Dr Doom giving everything
that's happened here Dr Doom still
stands to this day as one of the most
popular if not the most popular super
villain to have ever existed in the
history of Marvel
comics with that being
said God that was a metal fool 20
minutes that's
crazy that was awesome I think we did an
awesome job with that Dr Doom video I
think it was great so I'm going to go
ahead and bring this to an end I know we
skipped over a whole bunch of stuff and
what I'll do in the comment section is
I'll post list of some of the best
stories involving Dr Doom that way you
guys can go through and you can look at
the ones that seem to peque your
interest and uh and yeah so I will catch
you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from Comics explained and talk
to me
[Music]
directly just like you
find
findone just just like you just like
you you're a treasure in the sea